I'm so glad that you still go on tour
and you keep this tradition alive and
you know there's not a lot of guys doing
it on your level
so I mean but it feels like rock is kind
of gone in a way you know it's just not
as important to everybody as if to me
growing up there was nothing more
important yeah I think music is music
has had to share the cultural arena with
video games movie you know all
everything else everything you can
imagine and that's just that's today
don't you thank God you're not doing it
today like coming up and trying to do
yeah I gotta say I do you know uh we
came up in a golden age right what we
did yep you know yep if you were if you
were a young guy playing a guitar in
1967
1975
1985. uh you came up just as the the
whole that whole business turned into
something that no one ever thought it
would you know so it's a blessing you
know but I wouldn't want to be starting
now no no I don't know I don't know if
they if you can create
it's just a different world that's all
it's just a different world and it seems
unmanageable it seems like all over the
place at least you knew what to do you
go out and tour you'd make an album you
get it on the radio if you could there
was a way of becoming successful yeah
that's that's changed I mean
people still feel I mean my daughter
Taylor Swift fan to the max the other
day I pick her up at the airport says
Dad Taylor Swift it's got a banging new
record so I gotta bang a new record all
right and plays it for me top volume all
the way from Newark to Colt's neck you
know and dancing in her seat and I said
that's what I like to see you know it
felt it what'd you think of the record
you know it was good that was good she's
super talented you know her just a
little bit right she's a tremendous
writer and uh uh and I know we're
producer Jack Hatton off very well just
they're making big great records you
know so so those there's people out
there hey there's a lot of great work
going on people still making great
records and people are finding a lot of
joy in those records that's that that's
gonna go on it's just going to be
different you know and that's it
foreign